はい
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
いつでしたっけ
結構最近出した動画があるんですけど
うわでも結構経ってるな
一ヶ月前か
えっと一ヶ月前に僕
太りましたって動画出したと思うんですよ
この時の体重が
今、見返したんですけども
で、僕その動画で言いました
必ずモデル体型に痩せますと言いました
そして、あれから一ヶ月後
見せるぞ
俺のこの一ヶ月の努力を見せてやるから
まじ見とけよホント
俺、もう、本当
どれだけ頑張ったことか見せてやりますからね
じゃ、乗ります
はい来た、はい来た、あ　やべ　みるみる
はい来た X 3
はい X 6
もう何もしてないからね
はい X 2
これがもう今の体重です
↑ ↑ でございます
はーい、私は宣言した通り
この一ヶ月間で
多分みなさん気づかなかったと思うんですけども
結構この一ヶ月間
僕色々やってましたからね
完全にもうお腹もなくなりましたし
なんだろう、なんか
太ってる自分より
しゅっと、すらっとした自分が好きだったんで
このままもし体重が増え続けると
本当にただのデブになっちまうなと思って
もう自分で絶対痩せなきゃと
言い聞かせて
結構とんでもない方法でやせました
というわけで今回痩せた方法を
みなさんにご紹介しようと思います
ガリガリじゃないけど結構細くなってるよ
たぶん僕がもやしって言われ始めてた時期ぐらい
たぶん細くなってました
一ヶ月で何キロ落としたんだろう
僕の身長のモデル体型が ↑ ↑ なので
モデル体型でございます
↑ ↑ から ↑ ↑ まで減らしたら
7キロか
一ヶ月で7キロ減らしたんですけども
実際増え始めて思ったんですけども
なかなか体重って落ちるもんじゃないです
僕もすぐにパッと落ちるんじゃなくて
落ちないかと思って頑張ってたんですけども
気づいたら徐々に落ちてきてたみたいな感じで
もう気合いで痩せてやったぞ本当
実際マジでやってみたら大変だと思うし
なんかこう、なんか
体の危機を感じつつもやってたんで
死にそうです
たぶん真似しないほうがいいです
まずはですけど僕、運動する機会がそんなにないので
運動はほぼしていません
たまに誘われてバスケしに行ってたぐらいで
基本的にそれ以外何もしてないんですけども
結局ね、なんで太るかって言うと
ご飯食べて動けばいいんですけど
僕、ご飯食べても動かないから
たぶん太ったわけで
それを果たしてどうやって止めたかというと
こちら、最近の動画でも紹介してたんですけども
コバラサポートと
あと、特茶
特茶とコバラサポートで
僕はここまで来たと行っても過言ではありません
痩せようと決めた時からずっと
特茶を飲んでたんですけども
特茶は飲んでもね
お腹は結局減るんですよ
飲んでもお腹は減るんで
そこでちょっと考えを切り替えて
このコバラサポートってやつを
もう本当にね、アホほど飲みました
お腹空いたと思ったらすぐこれ飲んで
お腹を膨らませて
ご飯をなるべく食べない
最低限食べ..るんですけども
基本的にお腹が空いたら全部
コバラサポートを
飲んで X 5
飲みまくって
このドリンクでなんとか
お腹を..こう..保..たせるっていう作戦で
序盤の特茶が効いて脂肪が落ちたのと
これでそもそもご飯を食べないという作戦で
ひたすら体に肉をつかせなくて
こう、どんどん
削ぎ落としていく作戦で
ここまでやってまいりました
あのね、
あんまりおすすめしないです
なんかね、やっぱね
美味しいものを食べないと
心が荒んじゃうんで
自分との戦いでした
ここで食っちゃダメだなみたいな
こともありつつ
本当気合いでなんとか
６５キロじゃん
僕の中なんですけども
多分痩せるのはこれが最強だなと思いました
痩せてモデル体型まで戻りますって言って
まあ一ヶ月でできたな
一ヶ月で無事、体重を7キロ落として
モデル体型まできたと言うお話でございました
本当に痩せたいと思った人は
すごいおすすめですけども
死にます
あんまり真似しない方がいいと思いますが
そういう作戦もあるよっていう
お話でございました
もう太りたくねえな
みなさん、やせてしまったんですけど
もやしとは、言わないで
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓
もぉ↑　や↑し↑の↑漢↓字↓
【糵】み↓ん↓な↓で↑　お↑ぼ↑え↑ま↓しょー↓
【艹𠂤辛米】こ↓れ↓ら↓を↑　ちゃ↓ん↓と↓　合↓〜↑わ↓せ↑て↓
も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑や↓も↑やっ↓
もっ！糵っ！♬